hey what's going on is Bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 1st 2017 what's going on how
you like that echo I am in my garage
this is what it's come down to it's like
[ __ ] a quarter to 7 at 10:00 and 7:00
in the morning I got to go to the
airport
my lovely daughter is sleeping my wife
is sleeping there's no place in the
house for me to scream and yell so I'm
out here in the garage and oh by the way
unless by about an hour around 8 o'clock
there's people coming to my house
because well you know the gas line is I
don't know 96 years [ __ ] old
so that thing needs to be replaced
because it's leaking all over the
goddamn place that's always fun to have
a baby in your hands you set it down
towards the floor and you have to say
things to your wife like um do you smell
gas so getting that taken care of today
and this is it this is where my life is
at so I'm sitting here on my workout
bench that I can't use because I [ __ ]
up my shoulder gradually getting better
this is the longest most nagging [ __ ]
injury ever to try to heal but I'm
almost there
and this is how I'm going to do it
people this is I'm going to celebrate
this is the 10 year anniversary of the
Monday morning podcast can you believe
that for 10 years I have been yapping to
myself you know 10 years I have not been
reading 10 years I've been making up
[ __ ] for 10 years I've been saying [ __ ]
that I thought was true because I heard
somebody say it in an airport I've been
doing that for 10 years
I want to thank everybody's been
listening and I'm going to put a link to
a post whatever the [ __ ] you guys say
it's a it's a thing that you click on
and then it goes to the video that you
want to watch which would be the the
first Monday morning podcast ever which
I believe was about 90 seconds long I'll
give you
little history I was over Robert Kelly's
apartment back we still live right
around the corner of each other when I
was still living in New York City and I
was over his house and he was just you
know it was typical Bob he was just like
did ya you should do a podcast dude this
isn't to May of 2007 one of the few
things I've ever been at the beginning
of podcasting and getting a special on
Netflix those are the two things I was
at the front like I remember you know
for my intro and comedy clubs I would
say they like what do you want to say
say he's been on this he's been on that
and you can see he might have seen these
specials on Netflix and the host would
say it and people would snicker
they'd laugh in the crowd they would
laugh at that credit will now look at it
huh look at the feet the [ __ ] world
dominating behemoth you know there's oil
companies now that look at Netflix like
goddamn how the [ __ ] did you do that
without firing a shot
how the [ __ ] did you do that alright so
Netflix that Netflix in podcasting you
know if I was if I was on a oil company
I would I said I would do I'd start
coming up with some original content you
know what I mean and just make the show
so amazing you know that the stars would
then go over to those countries and
while everybody was fawning over the
cast of the reboot of friends I would
then run around the corner and I would
start stealing their oil that's that's
how I would do it you know it's a lot
less messy you know there's the
excitement am I gonna get caught right
anyways back in the day so I'm over
Bravo Kelly's apartment he's like good
you should do a podcast you and I was
like what is a what is a podcast in your
judges it's like a recording dude it's
another way to connect with your fans do
[Music]
now people listen to it next thing you
know you're doing this stress factory
Tuesday through Sunday dude and I'm
literally just [ __ ] around on it and
I actually I called it if you listen to
my first podcast you listen to the link
I actually said it I said this is my
podcast I was basically repeating
everything that Bobbie was kind of
yelling to me in the background and and
I called it I said and who knows maybe
this might lead to something mediocre
and you know what it took might have
taken me 10 years but god damn it I got
there Here I am sit near my [ __ ]
garage this is not some sort of cool
reverb that you're listening to this is
me and my grudge you know it's amazing
though is I got to tell you something I
don't know what it is it's I'm such a
cliched guy I [ __ ] love the garage
the garage is the [ __ ] you know I mean
it takes you back to being a single man
when you barely had anything because I
have one of those [ __ ] garages by the
way I was not going to be the person
that had the garage right that like you
buy [ __ ] and there's no more room for
this [ __ ] in your house and then you
take some other [ __ ] that you used to
like and you stick it in a box and then
you stick it in the garage right and
gradually it starts encroaching on the
car and next thing you know the car
can't be in there and it just [ __ ]
fills all the way up but you know what
you're doing you slowly becoming a
[ __ ] hoarder that's one of the
saddest things I assure you no I can't
understand whether it's sad or whether
it's um you just taking responsibility
for all the [ __ ] that you buy in your
life you know I guess anybody can take
it down to Goodwill anybody can throw in
the trash take it to the dump it takes a
real caring you human being a real
caring human being to just sit there and
in all that [ __ ] [ __ ] you bought your
entire life every [ __ ] newspaper
every tube of toothpaste
just sitting there suffocating in your
own [ __ ] carbon footprint you know I
just realized you know we shouldn't be
looking down at hoarders we should be
looking at these people going like holy
[ __ ] one human being what a human being
can buy all of that [ __ ] you know life
it's not even a lifetime they're still
living you know you can have that many
pets [ __ ] fish tags newspapers and
all of that crap I don't know how it
happened I'm sitting there looking over
right now you know my neat little
[ __ ] garage I got like two different
brooms I got this old [ __ ] mop I
don't know where that thing came from I
think it came with the house you know
and I've been meaning to throw that
thing up way does it end up huh [ __ ] it
in some beavers house some stupid mop
handle sticking through his little
[ __ ] thatch of a roof all those
things fast by the way I got those giant
goddamn teeth [ __ ] horse teeth doing
it so they can cut through the black
dude anyway so it's been 10 years and
I'm actually you know I had people on
Twitter send in some of their favorite
moments which I'll be reading later if I
could somehow get this [ __ ] computer
to work while I'm out here yeah so
anyways let's get on with the podcast I
didn't know if I even said it thank you
guys to listen
throughout the years thank you to
everybody who's booth advertised on the
podcast whether you like the read or you
didn't whether you got upset and said
I'm never going to advertise again
whatever was fun I had a lot of fun so
here's to the next 10 years I'm still
not going to read right I don't know
whatever you know what I like though I'm
a buck 76 right now I do like that way
176 pounds so I'm roughly the [ __ ]
weight I was that's probably a few
pounds lighter but I got to get down to
it I gotta get down the end of the month
next month my birthday I want to be like
170 171 right and you know what I get
down to that way I get down to that way
guess what then I'll be happy
uh-huh then it'll fill the void you know
when I go on I put my little [ __ ]
Tiger Woods golf shirt on even though I
don't [ __ ] in golf anyways is that
[ __ ] guy ever gonna win another
tournament it really bugs me really
[ __ ] bothers me that there's a bunch
of broads out there I think the reason
why he never won another [ __ ]
tournament was because of the [ __ ]
of his personal life give me a [ __ ]
break his body broke down that's what
the [ __ ] happened
this guy's a champion do you understand
what the champion could do a champion
can block anything out if you see these
guys going up trying to hit the [ __ ]
free throws
everybody just waving their hands
screaming a bunch of [ __ ] about the
guy's wife what is he doing
nothing but net nothing but [ __ ] it
you know this guy can't handle a little
spat he gets hit with a golf club he
jumps in his Escalade and he hits a
[ __ ] rosebush and all of a sudden all
of that talent goes away I don't know I
don't buy it I think and I think the
reason why some women some women look at
me being a little measured in the next
10 years some women the reason why I
think they attributed to that is because
I you know I think that they want to buy
into that whole [ __ ] thing is behind
every good man is a good woman get on I
mean which is so [ __ ] stupid right
obviously if you have a happy [ __ ]
marriage your life is going to be
alright but that's just another [ __ ]
you know everybody's always stealing
credit I always thought it was a
Hollywood thing until you get into a
relationship everybody's [ __ ] sits
there oh now I'm laying down there you
go now the back's better now the [ __ ]
backs better I don't know what I'm
talking about
did anybody watch the Formula One race
from Sochi in in Russia it's such a
weird name Sochi that sounds like more
like like a Chinese or Japanese
Vietnamese Sochi that does not sound
like Russian da EBU asteroid EA Sochi
that sounds too happy to be Russian but
I have to tell you it was a [ __ ]
that's a what a gorgeous city that is
huh you know what I mean I mean Russia
scares the [ __ ] out of me I grew up
during the end of the Cold War so I just
figured you're going to go over there in
the sec
if you have any sort of uh I don't know
American [ __ ] on it's just you know I
remember being in Finland being in this
cap and it blew my mind how close I was
to Russia it's like wow I can't believe
I'm this you know far east into Europe
and I asked the guy if he'd ever been
there and he started telling me about
Moscow how it was you know a little
dangerous after five you know and I'm
just let I just did the math of my head
it's like all right
this guy's saying it's a little
dangerous Finland beat Russia Finland
defeated [ __ ] Stalin okay Stalin
who's those [ __ ] people ran over the
goddamn Nazi army with their
mercedes-benz [ __ ] tanks right there
Porsche Jeeps
I can't name one [ __ ] Russian car
alright
just the sheer will and toughness of
those people you know you ever hear
those stories of them [ __ ] run around
in their socks in the middle of a
Russian winter just running the [ __ ]
German army right back to Germany you
know well where else would the German
army people go back to well I could have
retreated back to Poland God knows they
[ __ ] took that over right so I'm
thinking you know take a beat these guys
Jesus Christ what how the [ __ ] would
they lose to Finland you know that's the
championship match right there that's
Cleveland versus the Warriors Finland I
mean I was looking at them like alright
that's the [ __ ] Warriors verse I
don't know the Phoenix Suns but the I
don't know they'd [ __ ] be they
[ __ ] kicked their ass but what sucked
for them was at the end of the war when
Germany lost Italy fell and all that
[ __ ] when the Axis powers lost they were
on the wrong side of the [ __ ] table
so they went down with them it was like
a co-op you know what I mean like if you
pay off your shares in the building
you're like alright I own my apartment
it's like no you don't you won't shares
in this building but if everybody else
goes belly-up the whole [ __ ] thing is
done and then you lose your shares you
have to go back to renting your part
or you have to [ __ ] leave that's what
it was like and that's what happened
that they paid off their shares in the
building in Italy Germany went [ __ ]
bankrupt and next thing you know that
was it
and they had the giveaways like the
southern part of their [ __ ] country
or some [ __ ] they to give away basically
the stadium in which they won the game
they had to give that to them I'm pretty
sure that's what the [ __ ] happened so
when he was upset they got this is this
is the DNA that this guy comes from and
he's telling me that after five it gets
a little [ __ ] scary these are people
that [ __ ] you know look told Yosef
Stalin in the [ __ ] eyes you know
[ __ ] kicked his ass they like her own
[ __ ] cross-country skis cross-country
skis they beat these sons of [ __ ]
and this guy's nervous so it's just like
wow it's got to be a scary [ __ ] place
over there and then I'm watching the f1
race on Sochi right and it's [ __ ]
beautiful it looked like a Ron Howard
film starring Tom Hanks you know you had
a beautiful city in the background you
had went into a forest and you had
mountains and little snow caps on top of
it looked like a postcard like when they
take a postcard of Los Angeles
you know like once a year it's clear
enough where you can take a picture of
the downtown LA skyline and then see
snow-capped mountains in the background
right because they always say that you
know you can snowboard in the morning
and be surfing in the afternoon and if
you're in LA you're looking around going
with a [ __ ] your snowboard it's
because you can't see you can't see
through all the [ __ ] pollution so
anyway so I'm watching this goddamn race
from Sochi right and um I got to tell
you f1 f1 figured it out so far four
races in another really exciting race I
don't know what happened they made the
tires 30% bigger and all of a sudden
there's more [ __ ] grip but the
downward force all this [ __ ] that they
talked about it before every friggin
race I don't know what happened but all
I know and Ferrari made better cars now
all of a sudden it's at least you got
two teams racing Florida's supposed to
last year or was just Nico and
Lewis Hamilton so anyways
congratulations I hope I say speaking of
Finland I hope I say this guy's name
right mercedes-benz a tier 2 driver the
upstart the Tom Cruise and Days of
Thunder right
vault vault Terry bolt us I hope I said
that right he's like one of like nine
finished drivers to ever win a Formula
One race so congratulation him drove
great race Sebastian Vettel from Ferrari
second place Kimi wrote raking in broken
in his in his reckoning Kimi Sochi Kimi
kimchi Kimi räikkönen for Ferrari came
in third and then Lewis Hamilton came in
fourth I could say right now he wasn't
happy you know he wasn't happy that guy
doesn't give a [ __ ] if his car doesn't
work he doesn't get he'll [ __ ] run
his own teammate off the [ __ ] track
that's what I little I know about that
race all I know is if he's not winning
and his teammate can win he doesn't give
a [ __ ] he's not getting out of the way
you know he just doesn't give a [ __ ] but
then he also wins so whatever so I guess
that puts uh the [ __ ] his name I was
[ __ ] up Sebastian Vettel is in first
place he's got
I think he's got two wins in two second
places so you get 25 25 18 and 18 so
that's 50 and 36 got 86 points and I
think you know I'm in the garage do it
under the [ __ ] Internet as far as I
remember I think Lewis Hamilton has won
victory two second places and a fourth
so that's 25 18 and 18 Jesus Christ
what's at 61 36 and 25 that's 61 I'm
going to say at 61 and he's got a fourth
place where he gave her a fourth place
like 15 I don't know he's got like I
don't know we'll say 76 or some [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] know all I know is it's
shaping up to be a great year and for
whatever reason even though I have
german blood in me and no Italian blood
I actually I'm rooting for the Ferraris
just because last year was it get boring
Mercedes won every [ __ ] race so it's
good to see Ferrari back
and by the way shout out to Force India
I think they came in 8th and 9th of 6th
and 7th my fault for having the balls
they have pink cars out there or fuchsia
whatever you want to call you know
they've been like my my other team like
I want to see one of them win a race
this year I want to see a pink car win a
[ __ ] race it's just funny to me so
anyways I don't even know where the next
race is I would look it up usually you
know if I'm not [ __ ] laying on the
floor of my goddamn garage I would know
where the next the next race was I know
there's probably a lot of you when like
they'll let him [ __ ] you getting into it
first of all it's a great [ __ ] sport
second of law it doesn't take a lot of
time to watch there was 52 laps that's
it you can very easily add that you know
to whatever sports you're watching I'm
telling you even during the NBA in the
NHL playoffs because I [ __ ] watched
everything you know I wants to st. Louis
Blues right this weekend watch them
winning overtime game to believe was
Game two I watched so much [ __ ] this
weekend I watched the last two games
Anaheim versus Edmonton amazing to see
Edmonton like all of a sudden looking
like wait a minute these guys going to
be the Western Conference champions the
way they were playing and all of a
sudden they got the old right they have
Fred from the [ __ ] ducks in Edmonton
one of those weird series where the
three games in and the home team has yet
to win a lot of children going home
crying during that series so far and I
hate to say this as a Bruins fan but
[ __ ] Lou Cheech he looks right in
that uniform and I got a feeling he's
gonna stay there for awhile I don't know
what kind of contract he's he's I don't
signed up there but uh Jesus Christ he's
looking like the old Lucchese just a
[ __ ] force of nature I remember he
would like [ __ ] bring it over the blue
line and he sorta had control of it but
he didn't and he sort of just be kickin
it in into what somebody else is trying
to like [ __ ] stop em you just give him
a little [ __ ] floor arm the guy would
fall down he pass it over virgin run and
he scores I miss those days
anyways been watching that of course I
watch the Celtics [ __ ] wizards ah the
old sports rivalry that most of the
sports world does not realize is a
[ __ ] rivalry these two teams hate
each other but you know the deal it's
all about the [ __ ] Golden State
Warriors it's all about the Cleveland
Cavaliers and so no one's really paying
attention right no one's paying
attention to these two [ __ ] could be
they know it'd be like you know you got
the Rolling Stones and the Beatles and
everybody so I oh my god they're [ __ ]
amazing and then meanwhile Herman and
the hermit's doesn't get along with the
[ __ ] Partridge Family I don't think
we're that bad I'd like to think that
we're not that bad but anyway so the
first game like it give you a little bit
of a background whatever stupid reason
earlier this season the Wizards were
like we're going to dress all in black
when we play you guys cuz it's gonna be
it's going to be like a funeral I was
like oh JJ is that what you're going to
do and then what are we going to do not
try are you going to try extra nut extra
hard tonight [ __ ] wizards right so
even with that stupid little fashion
statement that they made they still beat
us so but not because they were black
they'd be is because they scored more
points so anyway so we're getting ready
to go see them we're getting ready to
play them and my buddy Josh Adam my from
the goddamn comedy gym and from the
Comedy Jam they had to clean it up on a
Comedy Central we decided that we're
gonna go down to a cigar bar we're gonna
watch the [ __ ] game together he's a
big Wizards fan and and he's a she's a
[ __ ] talker
right threes been talking [ __ ] you know
cuz I think they won this thing we'd
beat him like once and they beat us like
three times I can't even remember and he
was talking all this [ __ ] and at one
point they were ahead of us in like the
rankings they were number two we were
number three or something like that he
was just talking all of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] so the game starts cigar bar
doesn't open till 11:00 game comes on at
10:00 so I'm sitting there watching the
[ __ ] first quarter they go up to -
nothing
then his five to nothing seven and
nothing nine and not the [ __ ] twelve
and we have 16 to nothing case you
missed the game you don't have [ __ ]
SportsCenter or whatever sixteen to
[ __ ] nothing to start the game and
the game is it's over if it's any sort
of illegitimate
I will legitimate sport this game is
over and I gotta be honest with you I
will never like 100% be able to believe
that that basketball is not fixed I
don't understand it I don't understand
how one team can spot another team
sixteen points you end the first quarter
one teams on pace to score 120 points or
some [ __ ] and the other teams on pace to
score twenty I like seventy five or some
[ __ ] right or whatever eighty points or
something and somehow just it's always
it's a game of runs then I don't know
where they started like 16 to nothing
and then we go on like a [ __ ] twenty
five to eight run and somehow the score
is tied over up by like two at the half
I don't know when I drove to pick him up
and then we you know went over to the
cigar box was a little chitchat going on
and by the end of the third quarter we
were up by fifteen we were down sixteen
nothing thirty-six minutes of basketball
later were up by fifteen a 31-point
[ __ ] turnaround like doing when the
bills came back against the Houston
Oilers this basically that that happens
just about every other game in the NBA I
don't [ __ ] get it well it's a game of
runs it's a game is it how does one team
come out ice [ __ ] cold the other team
can't miss and then like like I've never
had a set where I go on stage and it's
just like I'm on and then all of a
sudden I'm off and then I'm on again and
then I'm off that's what happens in
basketball so we're up by fifteen Josh
is losing his [ __ ] mind he's standing
up he's pacing which is hilarious
because it's a cigar bar it's supposed
to be like totally chill he's [ __ ]
pacing back and forth
he's slamming down [ __ ] slices of
pizza you know like doing like stress
eating and I'm just laughing I was just
going like just it's the [ __ ] NBA
this game is going to beat I think now
we're going to do the fourth quarter and
because the third quarter ended the
switch gets shut off and the other one
gets flipped on and once it's going to
be a [ __ ] tie game so what happens
fourth quarter starts the [ __ ]
Celtics can't score a bucket for like
the first four minutes and next thing
you know like the wizards are down by
three and Josh is sitting down again and
I'm just laughing it's like how many
[ __ ] NBA games do you have to watch
what you really do if you just want to
if you really get into the games and you
feel like you're going to [ __ ] die a
thousand deaths what you should really
do is just watch the last two minutes
God knows that takes as much time as the
first [ __ ] 46 minutes just watch the
last two minutes because it's going to
be like a [ __ ] three-point game
anyways and whatever they have been
flowing that somehow the Celtics pulled
away again but I got to tell you it's
going to be a [ __ ] brutal series
brutal series and I think Jae Crowder
might get kicked out for one game this
could be some sort of physical
altercation I don't know what's going to
happen but looking into my [ __ ]
crystal ball I don't know who it's going
to be but somebody's going to get
[ __ ] kicked out of the game
gets suspended for a game because he's
[ __ ] team's hate each other and you
already started to see it happen a
little bit the first game I just they
just don't like each other but I gotta
tell you some I actually love that John
Wall guy I love when uh Josh showed me
this [ __ ] uh whatever the [ __ ]
Instagram picture or something like that
I guess a couple years ago they lost to
the Atlanta um the [ __ ] are they the
Hawks the Atlanta Hawks yeah st. Louis
Hawks to the Atlanta Hawks right they
lose to him and one of the guys on
Atlanta you know had a picture of them
in the final seconds of winning and John
Wall has a real sad look on his face to
do the post if it's real happy and then
there's another Lana Hawk looking at
John Wall laughing at him and I guess
John Wall didn't forget about this so
when they beat Atlanta he post a picture
and you know doing a crossover and the
guy who posted the picture fell on his
[ __ ] ass I love people that hold
grudges like that
I think that to be great you have to be
like that which is why Eli Manning is
such a [ __ ] enigma you know what I
mean
I swear to God like if you saw that guy
in the most in the final two two-minute
offense of a Super Bowl his heart rate
is the same is somebody at a [ __ ]
bake sale right outside of church you
know what I mean oh hey thanks for
coming out oh look how big your kids are
getting that's where his heart rate is
you know I swear to god they should see
and all those Dockers he's always
wearing what the [ __ ] sweater tucked
into them they should just make a
uniform just he completely psych out the
other team if I was the Giants I'd he'd
have like a special pair of football
pants they'd be the same color as
Dockers he'd still have the pads and
[ __ ] in it but you know some sort of dad
jeans so anyways I think the Celtics
wizard is going to go I think that's
going to go seven and I think it's going
to be [ __ ] brutal
I think the Wizards win the next one and
then I think we split down in DC I think
it's just going to go back and forth
back and forth back and forth that
evenly matched and I don't know why I
always forget the guy's name that
[ __ ] polish Transylvanian dude the
white dude with the shaved head whose
entire body is his [ __ ] heart as the
top of his goddamn head I mean that guy
looks like he could have played like
[ __ ] professionally could have played
like at least three different sports
dude [ __ ] plates men some gigantic
[ __ ] tight end you know
he's through his body he's like [ __ ]
white LeBron I know I know I'm got a
limb there but I'm telling you that guy
is a [ __ ] beast
I was joking with Josh Cohn his dad
[ __ ] grew up in Eastern Europe his
dad probably [ __ ] beat him with one
of those fireplace pokers right we're
all laughing I was certainly going like
that that can't be the name there's got
to be a different name for the fire
fireplace poker I'm just saying what it
does that can't be the name and I looked
it up and that's exactly what it's
called fireplace poker that's the best
they could come up with
they couldn't come up with some widget
name you know even with like the ladies
they got that thing they put in the air
somebody came up what's it called that
is called a flow be a what yeah a flow
be the [ __ ] is a flow be on something is
sticking your hair makes it do a couple
of whoop-dee-doo I don't know I'm
talking about let me do um let me let me
read a little advertising here and then
I'll talk about what a sad time it is to
be a Washington DC [ __ ] sports fan
Jesus Christ all the [ __ ] crying
these Cleveland fans did I ever see a
city cry as much as sated oh we do bunky
miserable I mean maybe they did that in
Boston back when we weren't [ __ ] win
it but I always hated that [ __ ] ever a
long time ago
ESPN did this hope they want to have
some trial like who has the more
miserable [ __ ] sports fans Cubs fans
a Red Sox fans I remember sitting at
home laughs and going dude I don't know
I don't know win this you want to be
more whoo [ __ ] wants to be the most
miserable you know who those [ __ ] the
kind of person you'd want to run into in
a goddamn bar you know I'm going to sit
there and just talk about how life
[ __ ] him over sorry anyways let me
read someone some of this advertising
here oh my god it's that time it's that
time of year when you can say I got to
get something for my mother
ProFlowers everybody talked about how
being a mom is often often a thankless
job and Mother's Day is a chance to show
your appreciation
I think that's talked about enough isn't
it it's only you know I want to see if
they have that copy for Father's Day
that it's a [ __ ] thankless job and we
take something right now all right this
is difficult a job as being a mother is
your [ __ ] babies are obsessed with
you my daughter barely looks at me she
just looked at me she smiles like hey
there's that guy that I kind of know but
my wife walks in the room she just like
she just follows her all around just is
looking at it I'm like hey hey other
parent other parent over here yo yo
you know what I mean you know when
you're at the game and they're throwing
free t-shirts into the crowd right and
you stand it up and then there's a group
of [ __ ] hell like hot chicks and [ __ ]
like like you're getting a t-shirt
doesn't stop you though you still stand
up [ __ ] flailing your arms never
happens so evidently for some reason
being a mom is a thankless job even
though everybody always talks about how
important the job is there's not one
presidential election that doesn't go by
where they don't talk about it
everybody's always saying you know
mothers are Saints and all of this type
of [ __ ] you know what do they say about
that they say nothing it's like we're
both on the same record label but only
their album gets hyped you know when our
[ __ ] do-nothing managers going like
you promised us at least one billboard
he's too [ __ ] fine you know you can't
even give us that but evidently I have
to do it again now Jesus you know you
just can't [ __ ] thank these divas
enough these mothers out there is
anything worse than we listen to a woman
say she lost herself in the relationship
you know and then you find it you know
it's one thing if you just you know if
you don't have kids but if a woman says
that and they have kids right there you
know what terrible mother she deserves
no flowers but the rest of you ladies
listen to this when you send the one
hundred blooms for Mom
Bouck bouquet bouquet whatever from
ProFlowers this Mother's Day you will
make a real impression oh yeah now your
mother's going to love you please listen
all their work in the sibling rivalry
into this these [ __ ] people have no
shame over their ProFlowers it comes
with a free glass vase for just $19.99
piece of [ __ ]
plus shipping and handling and if you
really want to make a statement you can
upgrade a preemie to a premium vase and
include gourmet chocolates for just $10
more gourmet chocolates for 10 bucks
okay
choose the delivery you want to buy this
f1 car for [ __ ] $11 is this the Wheel
of Fortune back in the day for $26 I'll
take the bread
nice bed frame I'll take the cuckoo
clock for 18 I'll put the rest on a gift
certificate you know what a year supply
of Trident gum choose the delivery date
you want and ProFlowers are guaranteed
to arrive fresh and beautiful and stay
that way for at least seven days or your
money back
the only way to get 100 blooms for Mom
with a free glass vase starting at
$19.99 is to visit proflowers.com click
on the microphone right at the top right
corner and use my code BIR that's
proflowers.com
and code bar when you click on the mic
this stunning bouquet bouquet sells out
fast so order today this is a great
thing you know what this thing is they
act like this is the one thing you need
to get your mom it isn't this is like at
least the thing you got to get for you
mom this is a great accoutrement -
something else I do it every single year
it's nice and [ __ ] easy and you know
what your mother loves flowers you know
why because moms are dreamers they
believe they believe that their
husband's not going to come home
hammered this is the time Angela's Ashes
he's not going right to the pub he's
finally going to take my kid to the
doctor and figure out what that [ __ ]
eye infection is you guys ever read that
book Angela's Ashes Jesus Christ you
know do you thought Charlie Brown had it
bad trying to kick the football [ __ ]
poor bastards waiting for that dad to
come home with the money never came on
went to the ghost you know spoiler alert
goes to the pub every [ __ ] time
alright Sherry's berries everybody
talked about a mom you really admire and
why well would that be my mom I'll tell
you as much as I love my mom there's a
mom down the street she just has those
vegetables Mother's Day is coming up and
Sherry's berries was that like some
politically correct thing like talk
about your mom well what about what if
the podcast mom
mom's dead what about that we want to a
[ __ ] avoid that [ __ ] Mother's Day is
coming everybody and Sherry's Fieri's is
offering huge freshly dipped
strawberries starting at $19.99 plus
shipping and right now you can double
the berries for $10 more pick your
delivery date and these berries are
guaranteed to arrive fresh and delicious
or your money back
you may think you've seen gourmet dip
strawberries before you know what I got
to tell you there's a lot of things I
think during the day and that was not
one of them you know what they look like
I don't even understand why they taste
so good
who the [ __ ] figure that out god bless
the person that did cuz these things are
delicious I will tell you that but you
have but you've never seen anything like
these Sherri's berries are huge sweet
juicy and covered in decadent toppings
chocolate chips chopped nuts white milk
and dark chocolatey goodness oh jesus
this is getting gross Sherry's berries
are an unexpected gift that will put a
smile on mom's face holy [ __ ] did you
drop 20 bucks on me that was unexpected
surprise the mom in your life with
Sherry's berries at her office slash
workplace
you can't send chocolate-covered
strawberries to your mom at work
everybody's going to think she's having
an affair the only way to get this
amazing berries deal starting at just
$19.99 is to visit Berry's dot-com click
on the microphone at the top right
corner and use my code bur that's
Barry's BERR IES com Bravo echo Romeo
Romeo India echo Sierra calm and my code
bur when you click on the mic this
amazing deal it won't last long and
Mother's Day is right around the [ __ ]
corner
so be sure to order now I believe it's
like May 14th this year so if I was you
I would just knock this out right now
and then wander into a mall and find
something else that you can get her you
know what I mean a [ __ ] Dutch oven or
some [ __ ] what does she do does she cook
for people even go to malls anymore but
you just go to amazon.com after go into
my [ __ ] website going to the podcast
page and clicking on the Amazon link so
I get a little doremi set my way sorry
all right here we go
oh look what's here but oh do me on DS
me on DS getting ready for Mother's Day
but do do to me undies
me undies drop your drawers and she'll
say hey yank up your velvety underwear
drawers stop shaking your ass they'll
think you're a male [ __ ] when you put
on your undies for Mother's Day I don't
know why I'm singing about my mom with
me undies Baba dabba doo doo - whatever
all right me undies everybody me undies
you need a place to stick your
chocolate-covered [ __ ] strawberries
right next to your own berries there you
go
and then [ __ ] there you go come in
pelvic pumping on Mother's Day and see
how she likes that all right why don't
you do that this year just fall on the
[ __ ] knife so every one of her mother
every one of your other siblings can
look like a great kid alright Jesus
Christ bill how do you sell underwear
after that well I don't know but we're
going to try all right elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies you've perfected your wardrobe
but what about the stuff not everybody
gets to see if you've been settling for
store-bought underwear five packs if
you've been settling for going those
prepackaged priests sewn together
[ __ ] underwears I have something that
will change your life for the better me
undies what is me undies Oh
the undies me undies velvety [ __ ]
underway epitome me undies V undies take
your balls out and everyone stares look
at it's a 10-year anniversary you're
getting two songs rub your nuts up
against the modal
grab your dog by the [ __ ] throat I'll
throw it outside cuz it took us [ __ ]
right next to your underwear drawer
and then go to jail for animal cruelty
alright me undies are designed in la la
Louisiana
Los Angeles who knows and made from
sustainably sourced micro modal hold out
a fabric three times softer than cotton
Biondi softer than soft luxury undies
come in an ever-changing selection of
classic colors bold shades and
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style I
think this is why Richard Simmons
actually disappeared once he could start
ordering [ __ ] velvety soft different
underwear every [ __ ] day you know
what I mean he probably is like I can't
wait these candy-striped [ __ ] shorts
anymore and that's my look you know what
I've made enough [ __ ] money I'm out
all right and guess what you can save
time and money okay frog in my throat
officer and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription and if you're not ready for
ascription well then go [ __ ] yourself
stay with your regular goddamn underway
you piece of [ __ ] no I'm sorry that's
all but that's not the copy
okay I'm sorry if you're not ready
that's okay a completely different
direction you can still say that's
because me undies is are for you 20% off
your first pair just use our special URL
the undies comm slash bar and get 20%
off your first [ __ ] pair so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer you deserve
it
once again that's my undies com / / my
undies dot-com / / biondi's me undies
revamping your underwear drawer boo doo
doo doo me undies me undies get some
fruity panties you [ __ ] they make them
for the ladies for their [ __ ] if you
don't have them
well [ __ ] it fell apart stamps calm
everybody I you know something I use
stamps calm
whenever I'm [ __ ] scented my fresh
pair of me undies out to Cleveland
hilarities or I'm going to be this
Tuesday and Wednesday I use me undies
whenever I'm whoring myself out sellin
posters and I'm a [ __ ] if I
figure out how to use their little
device God knows you can stamps a good
time and money which you can use to grow
your business right
what do whatever you want you know watch
your favorite clip from [ __ ] stroker
ace whatever you want to do I can mail
any letter any package you suggest a Mac
computer and printer and the mailman
comes and picks it up unlike the post
office stamps.com never closes right
under like unlike that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
used to date okay I'm saying this rug
was there legs never closed unlike that
prude this is just going out the risk
stamps.com never closes print postage
for letters or packages at your
convenience 24/7 7 days a week
convenient easy reliable flexible no
need to you know need to lease an
expensive postage meter right now you
can enjoy the stamps service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitments Jesus
Christ go to stamps comp click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in burn that stamps commenter
per stamps.com never go to the post
office again there you go you like that
person that graduated high school and
never came back to their hometown and
for some reason thinks that there are
success because they didn't you know you
don't makes you a success not leaving
your hometown it's how you treat people
and you know something that's one to
grow on
alright before I get into the questions
here let's talk about the washing to
sad-sack washington DC sports fan you
know i mean after all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
about Cubs fans Red Sox fans fans of
Cleveland sports meanwhile look at
[ __ ] Washington DC huh they have
nothing Nationals they went and [ __ ] the
Redskins have been a [ __ ] joke a
[ __ ] joke for 25 [ __ ] years I know
what you think will build a one three
[ __ ] Super Bowls in the previous
basically 10 11 years yeah but you know
something
they got some racist logo on the side
there was always
to take it away you know to me weirdest
thing ever they had some black guy
dressed up in the [ __ ] Native
American headdress maybe he had some
Indian blood in him I have no idea a
Native American blood whatever [ __ ]
you're supposed to say you know the
Capitals how many times they go when the
president's trophy get bounced out in
the second round they've won the kick
they won the Presidents Trophy three
times since 2009 and every time they've
lost in the second round and they've
dropped the first two [ __ ] games and
I was watching the end of this series at
home against the Pittsburgh Penguins the
reptilian ice water in their veins
Pittsburgh Penguins who I'm telling you
right now I'm going on and they're going
to win their second Stanley Cup in a row
you heard it here
you heard it now you play it later and
you will agree with me or you don't
never come back to [ __ ] podcast again
oh okay now I think they're just going
to repeat that's what it is they're all
dialed in they got Phil Kessel they got
Crosby they got the [ __ ] they got the
[ __ ] makka andre flower whatever his
[ __ ] name is theo [ __ ] flurry
whatever their goaltender's name is he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's out there
[ __ ] doing the old [ __ ] jazz hands
stopping everything that's coming right
marc-andre flurry they got jido I mean I
think they're just gonna overpower you
it's it or does Washington DC with the
Capitals they rise up from the ashes
then somehow figure out a [ __ ] way to
win Game three I was watching the NHL
Network this guy was going off going
this is the biggest [ __ ] game in
Washington Capitals history and III
agree they got to do this they got to
this and if they don't do this they're
going to blow up the whole [ __ ] team
it's going to be sad they got to start
all over again Jesus Christ how do you
not root for the Capitals in Game three
you got to do it I'm gonna be rooting
for him
dude Sidney Crosby I've been saying this
for your city Crosby's back hand it has
more [ __ ] velocity than most guys for
heads most guys wrist is in the league
it's [ __ ] insane thank God you know
something god bless his mother for
raising him right because I'll tell you
right now with his backhand
thank God he knows how to treat a woman
because if he didn't Jesus Christ he
would make Oh Jay look like a [ __ ]
Cub Scout
all right so Game three is coming up
definitely check that out and and with
that here's some of the people's
favorite Monday morning podcasts moments
MMP moments that's what Andrew wrote oh
we should have liked the little big eyed
smiling kids here douche bag of the week
Brad remember that don't care enough to
find the link but when Nia gave white
people credit for creating the jug
instrument it was incredible that was
funny oh oh then the classic member
granny [ __ ] water the poor bastards
probably still getting weird looks for
those who don't know what granny water
was this guy was playing some [ __ ]
game it kind of seemed like it was old
made but you didn't want it like if you
played the granny water card you [ __ ]
everybody else in the game so it came
it's time to play it and he's with his
girlfriend and they're playing with the
parents and out of nowhere for whatever
reason he decides to give him the Monday
morning podcast and throw on the f-word
when he played the car he just went
granny [ __ ] and won and there was just
dead silence and then he tried tried to
have to sit there to explain it to
everybody
the it's granny [ __ ] water listener
story from last year I think another one
granny [ __ ] water
the infamous rose bowl story had me in
stitches at work that was a time when
but we had put together a greatest hits
we really got to do that that was the
first Rose Bowl that we went to when we
stumbled in there and I [ __ ] lost my
balance and there was an old woman in
front of me and I had to like my forum
was in her back and she was kind of
leaning forward and I was a sitting here
going oh sorry and no one helped me up
because it was so horrified by the
condition I was in the only way for me
to get up was I had to push off of her
folded her in half off god I always get
this weird like feeling in my stomach
whenever I don't have I I hate that I
did that but I did
I apologize to have his grandmother that
was but I mean whatever she's a little
more flexible you know to enjoy the last
you know third of her life maybe um
another person Rose Bowl story with Joe
bartnik the old lady who kept getting
angry and calling her husband to
threaten you
mark no she wasn't an old lady she was
younger and that was the time she made
fun and she made fun of Joe bartnik
snows Janey had a big nose and he just
looked her and said you need to lose
about 30 pounds before you talk to me
[ __ ] and I was just like oh god all
right we're getting kicked out and then
she said she's like mark did you hear
what he said right so the guy turns
around to square off with bartnik
Bartnik just looks at I'm gonna use as
big as a [ __ ] Pittsburgh linebacker
so the guy takes one look at Bartnik and
then starts [ __ ] yelling at me and
start threatening to throw me down on
the field and you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
go right past bartnik Anne you go to old
[ __ ] bald carrot top
all right I'm a new listener he's his
favorite moan you asking me how she's so
loud wearing slippers and she's saying
that's why she's angry with you that's
love there you go
all right another one you answered a
question about a parrot like three years
ago that had me crying laughing at my
job I got in trouble I'll try to find it
I love how vague these are this is just
as vague oh this person like me for me I
just feel the Kardashian like it the
Kardashians could literally watch a baby
starve to death and then then they would
be crying you know Fanning their [ __ ]
eyeliner so doesn't you know smear going
like for me I just felt so sad because
for me it has to be that or the Kobe 11
you know God kelly olynyk and those
[ __ ] Kobe 11s it's the worst thing I
ever saw when you said Corey Feldman was
the Lee Harvey Oswald of the robot oh I
had to pull over I was laughing so hard
I don't even that doesn't make sense to
me anymore anyways let's see don't blow
it keep it simple count your money I
don't even know what that is when you
did the ad for draftkings one guy won
$1,000
one guys giving hand jobs for rent money
or something like that oh yeah that's
right I called that thing out for
[ __ ] being legalized gambling um what
else
TCU come on frogs
dude I called it barefoot [ __ ]
there's too many to remember I'm still
working my way through the older ones I
this is really making me feel good that
you guys remember all this [ __ ] all
right another one of the best moments
was when you told the story of going to
the basketball game and they kept
playing that everybody clap your hands
that's right and those all that crazy
[ __ ] going on Oh everybody loves this
read all zip a nature's box yeah I
[ __ ] that one up I called it it was
naturebox was the name of it I thought
it was like possessive nature's box and
I was like you're going down on mother
nature needless to say that was one and
done read and a full refund some point
we should put I want to put together all
the [ __ ] one-and-done reads that I've
had under the clip didn't make a dime
off those [ __ ] all right uh-oh the
Monday morning podcast Nia did you Minea
did you hear about Paula Abdul she was
like what I was like she's a former
backup dancer for the Lakers and now a
big pop star thought she died I did it
better the first time anyways when you
told Nia about not checking out funniest
thing ever oh yeah when I don't check
out at hotels I just walk out I'm done
done with you [ __ ] people when you
compared Harry Truman to the guy from
Shawshank am i being obtuse or your last
draft Kings read all right the Charlie
Murphy one no yeah yeah I was uh
I was a sad one but a happy happy
memories the Yoko Ono rant strawberry
pubes that's from the the Joe Rogan on
it read anytime you talk about cool cars
anytime you lean away from the mic and
ladies we're all human some of us are
good most of us are [ __ ] oh the big
tears big tears when Nia cry didn't um
where were we Italy they didn't know how
to comfort her I just kept going I was
hugging her and she was crying she had
like the biggest tears coming out of her
eyes like just fallin on my hands like
raindrops I was like hugging her from
behind you know she does she hit her
head that's why she bent down to pick
something up and it was a shelf and she
hit her head so [ __ ] hard my my even
my eyes like just watered like holy [ __ ]
and I didn't know how to comfort her so
she was crying I just I just started
reporting about what was going on I was
just going on I was going big tears big
tears all right as a STONER I find your
anti weed rants hilarious I get so mad
that I start hyperventilating the lovely
Nia everybody heads n not M it's not me
it's Nia like Nancy
Nia's story about hitting her head in
her big tears back tears already said
that one okay
you said Ric Flair wouldn't have come up
that fast I don't know what that is Kobe
Elevens why are you going to
Indianapolis bail all that [ __ ] freak
from the plane
let me see friends trying to get the rat
out of your new house story is it all
time favorite any time this is if oh
yeah when we were renting that house
when I got the [ __ ] kitchen redone
another [ __ ] zillion dollars I put in
this house I'm never going to get back
at one time you're talking about those
two guys eating [ __ ] while riding their
skateboard and motorcycle the
skateboarder crashing is the funny story
you've ever told that needs to be an
animal oh my god think we should animate
that you're so right at that time I saw
that [ __ ] guy in Griffith Park coming
down and he wasn't dressed like a
skateboarder and it was like 7:30 in the
morning you know when I was walking my
old dog Cleo
oh I missed that dog I'm going to see
her again next month I just feel with
like she's in college I still always got
a visitor look I love that dog and I'm
[ __ ] gonna be there someday when she
takes her final breaths I'm gonna [ __ ]
be there anyways yes I was walking
my dog and this [ __ ] guy came by like
the biggest hill in Griffith Park and he
was just dressed in street clothes and
it started wobbling oh my god a new
[ __ ] reference here like in MotoGP
the tank slap when it starts [ __ ]
oscillating you know and all of a sudden
they they can't get it to stop he
started doing that [ __ ] and just like I
don't I and find the clip because I was
more vivid when I just saw it it was one
of the [ __ ] most insane wipeouts it
easily could have taken over the agony
of defeat in Wide World of Sports
anyways um what else
how many six-year-olds could you kill
before they took you down you know I was
actually thinking about animating that
recently but after all the [ __ ]
psycho horrible [ __ ] that's happened in
the world since I did that used to be
funny you know and that's the world
we're living in it's not funny anymore
to me all right Doug Flutie heckling
story about a friend who takes things
too far maybe cry laughing at the gym no
idea which episode that was oh yeah that
was a buddy of mine who didn't know how
to talk [ __ ] I'll tell you that one
quickly
Doug Flutie came back playing for the
bills and was sitting in the end zone
seats and everybody's like heckling Doug
Flutie gonna kill the [ __ ] hey Doug
get to small blah blah blah blah blah
and my buddy wanted to get in and all
the [ __ ] talk and uh you know go back to
the CFL everybody's just trashing him
and my buddy doesn't know where the line
is and he also study or stutters and out
of nowhere he just goes hey hey hey hey
Flutie I hope your kid dies and
everybody in the end zone who was
hammered immediately sobered up just one
like uh-huh and everybody just set
shifts like to what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] brutal all right which also used
to kind of be amusing to me until now I
have a kid now I'm just kind of like
yeah that really wasn't like fun either
all right Jason marks I don't know what
that one is
draftkings final read and lastly but not
leastly don't wait to know know where to
find the link but the one that
introduced the great Pat Paul virzi will
you guys debated time travel that was a
good one that was a good one man all
right let me read I got time here to
read a couple of uh a couple of
questions here for the week
all right military virgin dear Bill of
the bore bu or warrior than what that
means I'll see you podcasts all the time
I also from time to time appreciate your
stand-up comedy that was a nice
backhanded compliment I listened to your
podcast all the time and also from time
to time appreciate your stand-up comedy
you know it's gone right from time to
time he makes me smile I am from New
Hampshire and your video tour of Hampton
Beach was right on the money I am
writing to you about my best but in the
military we are both in the service as
we became friends he confessed he
confessed that he's a virgin at the age
of 32 over the past two years since I've
known the guy he prefers to play video
games and he dunkaroos then going out in
public
Danka ruse with the [ __ ] of those he's
an exceptionally funny kid and has no
problem making good impression on
strangers or even a lady he just cannot
reach women in a sexual way
right now he's stationed in Europe in
good shape has a badass job speaks
French and his generally charismatic guy
he has every reason to be doubt drowning
in ladies and can even use the foreign
card but as I check in with them he
still hasn't gotten out from behind the
60-inch Plasma TV I don't know what his
problem is because he would always be
bitching about wanting a girlfriend I
think he may be whacking it too much the
new epidemic and another tidbit is that
he will turn to heavy drinking which
actually helps to open him up I can tell
he's not satisfied being single and
using alcohol but will not take the
initiative to break the cycle I'm pissed
because he's not using the golden
opportunity to slay over there and he's
just disrespecting and it's just
disrespectful to the rest of us that's
[ __ ] hilarious
um yeah man he seems I would say that he
should probably go to therapy and work
out whatever is hang-up is because that
could be a lot of [ __ ] that he's sick
and yeah it's that's sad I feel bad for
that guy you know maybe one thing like
some people just naturally like loners
and asexual whatever and they don't want
to be out there but whatever his deal is
you know be a sad thing if somebody
wanted to find love and they couldn't
find love that guy should be crushing it
if he can speak French and he can speak
English like that France that's your
whole [ __ ] world over there even if
you went to England and they don't give
a [ __ ] that you can speak English
because so today but if you go so bust
out some French BAM you crush on that
yes and he's a man in uniform dude this
guy he's like [ __ ] like three
different porno fantasies for women um
he's got it what is he going to do next
start cleaning pools delivering pizzas
yeah there's no reason for it I would
tell you buddy that he should go talk to
somebody about it but it's kind of
difficult if he's drowning himself in
booze and it's a delicate thing and it's
very difficult to get somebody to go get
help and they have to want to do it
themselves so that you're a good Fred
man because you actually give a [ __ ] all
right conspiracy theory sorry I'm
rushing through this I'm coming up on an
hour and these [ __ ] gas line people
going to be showing up soon conspiracy
theory uh bill what do you think of the
flat earthers it's a growing movement of
people who think we're being lied to
about the shape of the earth do you
think this is something you would have
bought into in your earlier more intense
conspiracy days no I wouldn't you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all you guys this is what I hate about
conspiracy theory conspiracy theory is
is everybody gets lumped into the people
think the moon is made out of cheese and
that they're shapeshifters and lizard
people okay all I was saying is that the
[ __ ] Federal Reserve is a privately
owned corporation which is a [ __ ]
fact okay I'll say things like I don't
think that the government or the
corporation's give a [ __ ] about the
people in Iraq because I saw the way
they treated these people in New Orleans
they don't give a [ __ ] about them they
don't give a [ __ ] about those people
over there okay so I don't buy that
that's
that's the level that I go to all right
I don't take it to this this is what I
would say to those [ __ ] flat earth
people okay okay let's just say the
earth is flat then wouldn't all the
ocean waters just run off the end of it
why isn't that happening
how do you explain that I would love to
talk to a flat earth person you know and
be like well why don't you guys do a
startup and get yourself a little
[ __ ] rocket go up in the [ __ ] air
it's like have you ever [ __ ] flown in
a jet you jackass you can look out the
window and see oh you'd see the
roundness of the earth um I don't know
but you know what I want to [ __ ]
watch videos of it I want to hear what
they think flat earthers are actually
more ridiculous than people trying to
enlike creationism or whatever believe
in Adam and Eve you know Adam and Eve
two white people that somehow created
Asians and black people and all that
type wish I don't [ __ ] get all that
well actually you know something yeah I
don't you know what I think I actually
believe believe with that type of [ __ ] I
actually think that I watched one of
those Neil deGrasse Tyson things and he
said you know we actually came out of
trees and I was just like you know what
is [ __ ] up as that is at least I can
look at a tree and be like there it is
that is a tree I could walk over I can
touch it I can climb on it it actually
made more sense to me than then Adam and
Eve I mean it's just uh-huh
I mean if you put like Adam if Adam and
Eve was a movie and then the Tooth Fairy
was a movie I mean I'd put them in the
exact same category and I don't think
that that's right all right conspiracy
theory I already read that one India
taking cash out of circulation
Jesus Christ bill just read an article
about India and freaked me out a little
bit last November India removed 86
percent of the country's cash from
circulation
most people are now using mobile payment
options and the artists II I don't know
what that means also goes on to say the
article sorry I got the laptop on the
floor that there was a TRC I the article
also goes on to say that ATM machines
and bank cards would be obsolete as
is 2020 in India not having physical
money and only using a phone for buying
stuff really makes me uncomfortable any
thoughts yet they're on their way to
microchipping all of us and once again
everybody's going to think that's
[ __ ] crazy you can go on the internet
you look at [ __ ] who work for
corporations that are like proud of
their [ __ ] microchip and their level
of security clearance that they have now
they're going to phase out [ __ ]
everything there's going to be cameras
everywhere you're going to be [ __ ]
microchipped and this is the thing it's
still not going to be enough control for
them they still won't feel comfortable
that they had that's how bad they're
[ __ ] you over that they need to have
that level of [ __ ] surveillance on
you that's how [ __ ] weird they are
and they want to see what you talk about
what you jerk off to and all this [ __ ]
if it's [ __ ] beyond creepy and I hate
when something like that gets brought up
unlike the [ __ ] news and all in the
best the news anchor can do is kind of
widen rise like okay that's kind of
that's going to be interesting and then
they immediately go to talk to us about
some [ __ ] old lady that you know just
you know made her own Jam or some [ __ ]
that's the feel-good story to get out of
it no it's unbelievably [ __ ] creepy
and I don't know I have no idea how to
stop it I have no idea how to [ __ ]
stop it because no matter what you do
people just sit there like I watched
this thing on on the news and they
showed a robot talking to a little
five-year-old kid and the robot was
going like if you put me in the closet
that would make me sad and like the
robot is preying on the [ __ ] emotions
of a five-year-old kid like that thing
should be illegal but do you realize how
[ __ ] up that make us they've always
done that with products preying on the
emotions of kids but to just see it in
that level of raw form and just sit
there and having this robot lying to a
five-year-old like it has [ __ ]
feelings I don't knows it means
everything seem like it's just really
sped up and we're just heading right
over the [ __ ] waterfall that's that's
what I think is going to Adam that's
what I believed anyways I actually said
my theory I believe that there's the
upper 1% and that they're going to get
its own microchipped and when they get
sick of that [ __ ]
they're going to sick the robots on us
they're going to take us all out and
eventually the robots will take over the
upper 1% and and not in the way you
think they're not going to kill them
they're just going to be like all
looking like supermodels and human
beings won't bang each other anymore
because it's gonna be this could be way
more difficult you know I mean be way
more [ __ ] difficult than banging a
real [ __ ] human being and then that
will just become extinct
alright overrated versus underrated
overrated giving a [ __ ] bill I just
turned 35 six months ago and I realized
how great life can be when you start to
only care about [ __ ] that pertains to
you oh I thought you thought this would
be like give a [ __ ] caring about your
fellow man this is completely for me
this is the other way I don't care about
anything anymore and my friends and
family say they really enjoy my company
more these days I wasn't yoga or Tony
Robbins it wasn't yoga Tony Robbins no
disrespect to either them
it was apathy alright maybe that's what
that [ __ ] 32 year old virgin needs
underrated waking up early I've been
waking up early for the last two years
in my life has changed drastically
everything I talked about doing I
actually do now and I'm in better shape
than ever because of that a you know
what I'll throw another one I'll throw a
good [ __ ] underrated out there
sausage I got this great [ __ ] butcher
you know a couple towns over and I make
the drive I make the drive that's how
good this [ __ ] butcher is and when I
go in there all I ever looked at was the
steaks I looked at the chops you know
the [ __ ] pork chops the chicken and
occasionally I would [ __ ] with the fish
but I blew right by the sausage I was
just I don't I just never was into it
you know it's weird I'll have sausage on
pizza I'll have it in an omelet but I
never gave a [ __ ] about it so I was on
the phone with the lovely Nia and you
know we've been going there a lot and we
were kind of running out of options
we've done all the steak [ __ ] we've done
the [ __ ] pork chops I don't [ __ ] with
veal though there's no need there's no
need to do that to an animal you know
what I mean just let the thing run
around and give it the old [ __ ] right
there Fred
anyway so I was just like I don't know
what do you want to get now it's just
that I was just sort of as I was
I knew I looked over at the sausages
right and there was one that looked like
this [ __ ] giant like black porno dick
right so I look at I go what the [ __ ] is
that and it said it was short ribs
sausage with cheese uh-huh so I said I
go near he's got these [ __ ] porno
black dick looking sausages here that
say this short rib with cheese she goes
get those right I don't know if that
sounded delicious or just she's sick of
being with me but anyways I got two of
them right and this just really just
become some big sexual thing no my wife
did not have a threesome with them we
actually had them for dinner ah so
anyways we came home cooked those
[ __ ] things up in the skillet made
some pasta and a little bit of [ __ ]
sauce for it and it was [ __ ]
delicious and now now I'm all about it
now I'm just thinking once again I went
on the Big Green Egg I want to learn how
to [ __ ] make pizza right maybe just
cheat get the [ __ ] pizza dough I can
make a good enough sauce I get some
fresh cheese and I go down the street
get the [ __ ] porno dick [ __ ]
sausage right pull a little Lauren
Lorena Bobbitt chop it up put it on the
[ __ ] I'm sorry
you know what underrating you know it's
difficult rying to talk about sausage
and not going into the porn world I mean
what do you want to do you [ __ ] Lanie
looking at it's a giant [ __ ] meat
alright that's the podcast the ten year
anniversary I want to thank all you guys
for listening uh this podcast it
podcasting in general has changed
comedians lives it's such a great way to
connect with you guys promote our shows
I'll be at hilarity Tuesday and
Wednesday I've had such a great time
doing this it's actually helped my
stand-up and I'm going to continue doing
as long as you guys [ __ ] listen
alright that's it here's to another 10
years
porno sausage
all right I'll check in you on you don't
take any [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday all right
see